I just woke up I don't have contacts in
and I'm driving I can see shout-out to
KY for doing this with me
rise and shine it's a new day and Kylie
Jenner and her busty Stassi are seeing
everything in a whole new light as you
can see we can the duo recently
underwent surgery together
Lisa Chi surgery they're both too scared
to do it by ourselves
Stassi documented the procedure on her
vlog in a 10-minute clip that also takes
fans on a food tour shows Kylie passed
out in daughter Stormies room and
documents Stassi undergoing a breast
implant surgery as well as the LASIK
procedure we just finished our surgery
how do you feel loopy true to form the
girls decided to celebrate their vision
in the most epic way and I just got a
text from my friend who's crazy saying
that we're throwing a party tomorrow fer
the fact that we can see we have outfits
hair makeup location props decorations
all being sorted and she wasn't kidding
my husband for birthdays we know Kylie's
obsessed with eyes stormy it reminds me
she's my twin I prayed and prayed that
she would have like my big eyes and she
is like the biggest eyes ever so her
decision to undergo LASIK doesn't come
as a huge surprise I guess you can see
[Music]